I'm not a person normally to make a a
thing of titles but it does seem
appropriate as KITT just reminded me
that I should introduce myself I'm the
Henry or a loose director of the
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies and it's a real privilege
for me to be able to welcome everybody
to this event which is the brainchild of
of Paul Needham and kit Luce as as the
real movers and shakers behind today's
event which is really terrific for us to
be here and able to hear about these two
new biographies the master of ceremonies
of the panel is Shelly Kagan who was the
first Henry or loose professor of social
thought and ethics at Yale and so it's
it's it's a we're all in the family here
today but nobody came to listen to me
so I am gonna turn over the podium to
president Levin welcome everybody well
it's great to have everyone here at
Henry Arliss hall for this very special
occasion I'm delighted to see so many
members of the Luce family here today in
this hall which they established through
the loose Henry the Henry Luce
foundation in this hall that essentially
the Luce family built this building in
fact in the spirit of the man that it's
named for has helped to engage Yale
students and faculty with the world
around them which of course was what
Henry Arliss was all about and it's
enabled great scholarship in the fields
of international and area studies many
of Yale's international initiatives over
the past 15 years that have brought this
university global recognition have begun
right here in this building and I'm
truly grateful to Liu's family into the
Henry Luce Foundation for their
generosity to so many activities and
programs at Yale over the years
this is a very special time for those
who are interested in the life of Henry
are loose because the two scholars who
were privileged to have here with us
today are both about to share with the
world a more thorough examination of
Henry Lucis life that has ever been
available before both are working on
biographies to be published in one case
very soon and as we know Henry Luce was
among the most powerful and imaginative
communicators of the 20th century he
graduated from Yale in 1920 like the
organizer of today's event Paul Needham
he was the editor-in-chief of the Yale
Daily News and he and his classmate
Britt Britten hadn't found 'add their
first magazine Time magazine three years
after graduation time was truly unlike
any other publication available in 1923
its first in his first issues
subscribers learned that Joseph cannon
the once all-powerful Speaker of the
House had retired and they learned that
there was a famine in Russia time was
ambitious in the breadth of its global
coverage and also distinctive from the
beginning in its use of pithy and often
amusing language hadn't died at a very
young age but Luce pushed forward and
ultimately built time incorporated into
a which became as we know which I am
pyre he founded fortune and life and
Sports Illustrated
and he was once referred to an arrival
publication business week as being as
close to a lord of the press as America
could possibly produce these are course
of the basic facts about loose but we
are especially lucky that we have Alan
Brinkley and Lance Morrow here today who
have each explored their lives in great
detail and have forthcoming biographies
that will surely shed new life on and
release his life and on his influence on
America and the world Alan Brinkley is
the Allan Nevins professor of American
history at Columbia very well-regarded
American historian and he also did a
stint for five years as the
most of Columbia University undoubtedly
delaying the publication date of this
great biography but we're all looking
forward to it and the biography will be
called the publisher Henry Luce and his
American Century
that's Morrow is the author of eight
books and was for many years an essayist
and senior writer at time and I'm sure
many of you are familiar with his work
over the years and he remains a
contributor there he won the National
Magazine Award for essay in criticism
and he twice shared other national
magazine awards from 1996 to 2006 he was
a university professor at Boston
University and his biography is still in
progress
our moderator Shelly Kagan has e'en told
you was what he first came to Yale was
appointed as the Henry Art Loosed
professor of social thought and ethics
and today he occupies the Clark
professorship of philosophy at Yale
we're very glad that Shelly's taken on
the burden of keeping our panelists and
our audience on track in today's
discussion and once again I welcome you
all to Yale and Henry Luce Hall for what
should be a really interesting hour
thank you
our format is going to be fairly
straightforward I'm going to ask each of
our two speakers to speak for about ten
minutes each and then after that I'll
ask whether either them has any quick
reactions to the other person's initial
presentation and then once that's over
we'll open it up for questions or
comments from the audience so without
any further ado I'll first ask Alan
Brinkley to speak thank you well it's
it's a pleasure to be here at Yale and I
want to thank several people Paul
Needham and kit Lewis for organizing
this event
Peter Luce is here and it was a great
help to me and I thank you in absentia
Hank Lewis Henry Luce the third who
unfortunately is no longer with us
my original title for this book was the
missions of Henry Luce and that title
was Scotch try my publishers but and
probably rightly so but I do think that
it says something about the life of
Henry Luce he was as I'm sure you all
know the son of a Presbyterian
missionary in China and much of his life
was shaped by the culture of the
missionary world that he grew up in Luce
was as as you've just heard the
co-founder of Time magazine longtime
ahead of time incorporated I and I want
to argue that he was in many ways a kind
of revolutionary and unlikely
revolutionary certainly he was the son
as I say of a missionary a missionary he
was the product of elite boarding
schools he was a skull and bones Minh at
Yale he was an ardent Republican through
who most of his life he was one of the
wealthiest men in America and lived
accordingly he disliked most of the New
Deal and loathed Franklin Roosevelt he
said after Roosevelt's death it is my
duty to go on hating him
his famous 1941 essay in life the
American century was a call to reshape
the world on the American model he was a
passionate champion of America's least
popular Wars if he had his way the
United States would have used both the
Korean and the Vietnam conflicts to
unleash Chiang kai-shek and join him in
overthrowing the communist regime in
China but what made Luce a revolutionary
figure was not his politics or his
religion or his missionary zeal it was
his success in creating a new era of
communications that had an enormous
impact on the culture of the 20th
century at the precocious age of 24 Luce
and his brilliant a classmate and friend
and partner and rival Brett hadn't
created the first news magazine a word
that they'd invented themselves time was
something almost completely new a
concise summary of the news of the world
published weekly marketed throughout the
United States and later around the world
it wasn't to everyone's tastes with it's
deliberately IDIA syncretic language and
it sometimes
arch opinions but for the hundreds of
thousands of men eventually millions of
readers most of whom had in the past
received news only from provincial local
papers time was among the first
publications that made the news of the
world available to people in all parts
of the nation time became in a way a
kind of glue providing a professional
and other mostly middle-class people
with a common reliable and concise guide
to information that was now more
important to them than ever before
a hadn't died prematurely of a strep
infection in 1929 a few days after his
31st birthday but Luce moved on without
missing a step in the first months of
the Great Depression he launched the
first truly serious business magazine in
1930 fortune which was a dazzlingly
beautiful magazine but also a magazine
written by some of the most talented
writers of his time
six years later Luce launched the first
issue of life perhaps the most popular
magazine ever published in America it
wasn't the first picture magazine by any
means but it was by far the most
creative and successful and it offered a
visual image of its time I revealing as
Luce wrote in his famous prospectus the
faces of the poor and the gestures of
the proud strange things machines armies
multitudes shadow in the shadows in the
jungle and on the moon things hidden
behind walls and within rooms things
dangerous to come to Luce launched other
innovations as well time marches on the
first newsreels that offered real
documentary features won an Academy
Award for its creativity somewhat rigged
academy award I have to admit but
nevertheless an Academy Award
there was a weekly national radio
program drawn from time and in 1954 the
first really serious sports magazine
Sports Illustrated began publication
from the mid 1930s through the late
1950s time incorporated was probably the
largest news organization in the world
with bureaus on every continent and the
reporters active in almost all nations
they claimed to reach over 20 million
people every weekend even more during
World War two which the Time magazine
timing magazines reported at least as
intensely as any other organization the
company's great success was partly a
result of shrewd management and lavish
but usually careful budgeting but it was
also a result of Luce himself who had
looked into the future and had seen an
increasingly indicate integrated nation
and world that would more than ever need
a vast amount of information and an
efficient way of accessing it he
embraced that future and he created the
vehicles that served the needs of his
own rapidly changing time so I think
I'll stop there and turn this over to
Lance and I want to
helped pleased I am to share the table
with Lance Morrow whose I think I've
been reading most of my life and well
thank you very much this is this thing
on it is so good well I'm delighted to
be here and I'm grateful to be invited
by Paul and KITT and I'm very pleased to
to be sitting here with the author of a
of a terrific book on loose the best one
that's been done in my view that's so
far it's I don't know whether he's got
the advantage on me or I have the
advantage on him because I have the
later word than he but anyway I know
what he said he doesn't know what I'm
saying what amazes me is the is how
controversial Henry Luce remains there's
a sort of a scissor curve but I was
wondering today whether people a person
of 25 really is aware of who Henry Luce
was and yet I was reading a review of
the account the Economist reviewed
professor Brinkley's book and it
contained the following statement Henry
Luce was wrong about everything
that was the reviewer not frankly
talking but when I graduated from
Harvard in 1963 one of the speakers at
the commencement went into a long
sardonic riff on the words time and life
and the the gist of this conceit mmm was
that after four years in the rarefied
purity of Harvard we were about to be
cast out into the America that Luce made
when when and and I was not only cast
out I was astonished eighteen months
later to find myself going to work for
Lucis magazine I never met
he had retired just before I came but my
mother who was an old lefty from the 30s
and a New Deal and eventually an Adlai
Stevenson Democrat was so ashamed of my
going to work for her for a loose
magazine that she would barely talk to
me about it and she remained she hated
Luce almost as much as she hated Richard
Nixon which was a very great deal Robert
Hoover wrote a book about the the
execution of Julius and Ethel Rosenberg
called the public burning and in the
public burning time is presented as the
poet quote poet laureate and loose and
this is the unkindest cut for the son of
a missionary is presented as a kind of
Antichrist he is everything that the bad
America represents there is if you'll
permit me for a moment there's a there's
a motif that I found amusing a motif of
assassination or would-be assassination
that runs through the whole Luce story
in the early 1930s when James Agee was a
young writer at Fortune magazine sitting
in his office high in the Chrysler
Building in Manhattan he would have at
night fantasies of walking down the hall
to lose his office pulling out a pistol
bracing it on luces desk and shooting
him and his fantasy in his fantasy all
the other writers and researchers would
peak like liberated prisoners out of
their offices and would cheer James Agee
as he came out of the having having done
this deed I must say having worked at
time for many many years I completely
understand the impulse
there were times the what felt that on
deadlines and so on but in in 1945 there
was a Marine loose went over to China
just after the after the end of the war
and there was a Marine who was
disgruntled about not having been
shipped home yet and he blamed henry
luce for the fact that he aimed he
obviously somewhat disturbed but he
aimed his rifle at the back of Lucis
head and only because a buddy talked him
down and out of shooting loose ok Pearl
Buck who was another mich kid but of an
entirely different her father was a
completely different kind of missionary
from from Henry winters Luce the
Reverend Henry winters of Pearl Buck did
an absolutely scurrilous novel called
God's men which was published in 1949 in
which she portrayed Henry Luce she
loathed Henry Luce and she portrayed him
as a monster who ran a large obviously
it was loose and obviously her the the
the newspaper Empire that that this man
ran was Time Inc and it's an 11th the
assassination of Luce basically and
presents him it's it's sort of
hysterical that repeatedly practically
every other page Shearer informs us that
her title character Luce had very tiny
hands that were covered with black hair
the Swanberg biography that appeared in
1972 w a Swanberg who was a Norman
Thomas socialist out of the mid 30s out
of the minica Minnesota farm Democrat
Labor Party and whose real American hero
was Norman Thomas Swanberg took after
Luce and wrote a the most relentlessly
hostile book about Luce that I've ever
seen almost about anybody and that
became a kind of
a premature last word on loose I'm
delighted that professor Brinkley and
that I am are returning to the subject
because for a long time
the Swanberg verdict on loose was fairly
widely accepted as the verdict on loose
there's something of an Istanbul effect
with Henry Luce Istanbul if a person
approaches Istanbul from the West he is
struck by the city's Eastern
characteristics if you approach Istanbul
from the east you are struck by what a
Western city it is if you approach Henry
Luce from the left he seems an
incredibly conservative and to Swanberg
reactionary a crypto Nazi kind of
character if you approach Henry Luce
from the right he may seem quite liberal
and indeed he was on many many subjects
he was a man who had far less
consistency than the Swanberg cartoon
would have you to believe and he was he
was a man with a very open and
independent mind of he had a very
penetrating mind a probing mind people
were who worked for him were terrified
by his to be confronted by him because
he did not like people who agreed with
him in a facile way and he he worked
them very very hard I have a friend
named Chris Porterfield who was a Yale
graduate who told me a story about he
wound up being an assistant managing
editor of time but he told me that when
he was a young man starting out in in
1961 as an intern at time he was on the
Washington bureau the Washington bureau
was having a dinner for Harry Luce who
had come down to talk to the
correspondents
Chris was very nervous about this
because he didn't want to talk to lose
but then he decided he's not he couldn't
possibly pay any attention to me I'm the
junior man on staff he doesn't know who
I am
loose walked in the room looked around
saw Chris Porterfield this kid and
brushed aside everybody else and went
relentlessly to this guy and said you
know who are you what's what's what's
going on where are you from Minneapolis
oh you're really what's going on in
Minneapolis I'm gonna come on give me
give me that what's what's and Chris was
totally at a loss and he said well you
know and it was June it was it was late
May or June so the weather was warmer in
Minneapolis he said well you know people
are going out to the banks of the
Mississippi how are they really what are
they doing up there having picnics
really well tell me more and you know
they will build little fires sometimes
and they'll play the ukulele and he says
the ukulele really no kidding and then
John Steele who was his bureau chief was
right over his shoulder and loose corner
of his mouth you hear that John the
ukulele they're still playing the
ukulele in Minneapolis and what do they
call this they call it River banking you
hear that John River ranking so John
Hersey who worked for loose for a long
time or for a while anyway the the
novelist John Hersey wrote a sketch of
him once in which he said the most
attractive thing about Henry lives and I
think this was absolutely true was that
he was relentlessly curious about
absolutely everything he was delighted
by any fact to learn any fact that he
had not known before and sometimes this
seemed almost fetishistic in the way
that he he is there are famous stories
around time of the terror that he
excited in bureau chiefs who would go
and rehearse the route in from the
airport to know what every building and
was so that they would be able to answer
John O'Hara the novelist John O'Hara
once said that the most that he O'Meara
was
extremely fortunate as a novelist to
have the most exciting material in the
world that is to say that develop the
development of the United States in the
first half of the 20th century well had
that was Henry Lucis material and it was
very very rich material that he and
O'Hara wrote novels loose published his
magazines and as Professor Brinkley said
it was a kind of glue he gave Americans
an image of themselves Americans are an
extremely self-conscious people and they
need to have an image of themselves they
need to know what they think of
themselves and it seems to me that the
an interesting point about Luce and his
magazines was that 52 weeks a year they
gave to Americans a running picture of
themselves losses critics made much of
the fact that Life magazine in the 50s
for example seemed to emphasize too much
the unity that this was a vision of
America that they his critics thought
was already artificially unified there
was too much it was too pretty almost or
too middle class in fact Luce addressed
a lot more than the middle class the
point was that the middle class was in a
state of movement a dynamic movement
after the world war want to rather the
GI Bill the the whole meaning of Time
Inc '''l in a in many cases had to do
with the enormous changes that were
happening in America but loses vision of
America was centripetal not centrifugal
and his I don't know if you remember
I'll shut up in a second but the the
edward hicks was a in the early 19th
century was a a Puritan or rather not a
Puritan a quaker minister and a folk
painter
whoo you may remember his paintings of
the peaceable kingdom in which the wolf
flies down with the lamb and they and
the every that they're lovely actually
he did 30 different versions of this
well if it's not too extravagant to say
so I believe the the Life magazine that
his critics were criticizing was a sort
of 20th century version of that
centripetal vision of a certain unity in
in the American proposition in the 60s
America became centrifugal rather than
centripetal and the 60s were the decline
in fall well Luce died in 67 just as the
United States was descending irrevocably
into Vietnam the centrifugal voices were
everywhere he in 66 Luce went to
something called the hunt ball which was
the life magazines annual staff party
George hunt was the managing editor of
life loose for the first time very
uncharacteristically spoke to the staff
critically of an article that appeared
in life it was by a guy named Barry
Ferrell who was a staff writer and the
the the article had compared favorably
Allen Ginsberg to Walt Whitman this
outraged loose and it was precisely the
difference between the centripetal and
the centrifugal he said Whitman vision
of America was a centripetal embracing
vision which he believed profoundly
amazingly enough Whitman believed that
his poem could stop the Civil War from
happen it could prevent the Civil War
because it was an embracing vision
Ginsberg in Lucis perception was
divisive centrifugal negative and it it
offended something very deep in Harry
Luce that his own magazine life
would favorably compared allen ginsberg
to Walt Whitman I'll stop there I've
talked too long well I don't I don't
disagree with anything that that lance's
said I maybe will return just for a
moment to the Swanberg book which you
began with of course that was the first
book about Henry Luce that that I ever
read I picked it up at the Strand in New
York many years ago long before I had
any idea of writing a biography of Henry
Luce myself and and I read it and I was
a used book of course I and on the
Flyleaf
somebody some probably undergraduate had
written on the Flyleaf a great hatchet
job and 99% true but I think Lance is
exactly right that Swanberg who was
indeed a Norman Thomas socialist in fact
wrote a biography of Norman Thomas like
I sat at a table next to him in the New
York Public Library when he was doing
research there and his biography of
Norman Thomas was as adoring as his
biography of Henry Luce was as detesting
so I I think Henry Luce does need to be
reconsidered there is a very good book
short about Henry Luce by Henry James
bellman which was part of a series of
short biographies that was published Oh
maybe almost 20 years ago but there's
been very little else that I think
really does justice to Toulouse and so I
hope that the two of us maybe will help
remedy that I I think the the Bauman if
I may have it just up just a second the
bellman is it's good and it's a lot more
temperate than the Swanberg book but I
still feel that that Bauman
there are there are solace isms in
Baughman that I find very strange for
example he's he's a he's a member of the
Vietnam generation and the Vietnam
generation used the words Hawk and Dove
with it with a particular specificity
referring to the Vietnam period well he
uses Hawk he applies the word Hawk to
Henry Luce in the American Century
editorial in early 1941
as if it were a negative or pejorative
term it which seems to me to stand
reality on its head and shake it upside
down it to be a hawk in 1941 when Hitler
has long since invaded and Poland and is
overrun Western Europe and Western
civilization is that close and there's
Lindbergh is is running around the
country giving isolationist speeches and
Kingman Brewster is one of the partners
in the founding of America first at that
moment to use the word hawk on loose
sound that seems to me preposterous
so I quarrel with the bellman thing I
die
I admire some parts of it but there's
something Loused up in the and the I
don't know the the loose makes people
mad in an interesting way I'd and he
made me mad when I mean I didn't when I
went to work for time in 65 I didn't
like him much I didn't I didn't ever met
him but I didn't like him much but he
there's something that really angers
people about Henry Luce and all these
years later he remains somewhat a
controversial figure very good let's
open it up for questions from the
audience I'm going to ask you when I
call on you to please stand and then
I'll try to summarize the question
briefly so that everybody can have heard
it so any questions at all yes
thank you just to repeat the question it
was in working on somebody's biography
one often changes one's emotional
reaction to the person over the course
of working on it and so the question is
how did either of you find your feelings
about Luce changing in the course of
working on the book ts Matthews who was
a an editor of the of time for a while
and and was close to loose for for quite
a while once said something about Henry
Lewis he said he's he's not a likable
man
but there's something lovable about him
and I found myself understanding that I
must say that that for me although I his
manner people who knew him found him I
was speaking the other day to to to a
guy who was a top editor at time
who knew loose and I said well what was
he like and he said well he was
I liked him because what you saw was
what you got but there was something
uncouth about him I said what really
uncouth is that's an odd that's a strong
word soiled blunt kind of blunt slightly
ill-mannered my theory was that that
blunt manner was a way of that he dealt
with the staff with it he could dispense
with a lot of amenities and he could he
could sort of get to the point I also
think that if you read pilgrims progress
bunions bunions Christian is very rude
in exactly the way that Henry Luce was
said to be rude if mister worldly wise
men tried to steer Christian off the
straight path he was very rude to him he
was very brusque and rude and said you
know don't and any and when he was in
Vanity Fair
of course Harry Lewis married the former
managing editor of Verena Vanity Fair
but Clara's but but when when John
Bunyan was in in when Christian was in
Vanity Fair
he was quite rude to some people but
anyway I found myself rather
unexpectedly for myself liking Luce a
lot more than I thought I would I mean I
certainly am very much aware of his
faults and so on and he was to say the
least
a stigmatic about certain things but I
found myself liking him and finding that
I thought that others had really missed
the point about him that there was some
that he wasn't what he seemed that there
was something else going on that the
game you saw wasn't the real game that
there was something else and that's
where I am now I think I think that an
awful lot that has been written about
him has simply missed the point of Henry
Luce well I I started working on this
book deliberately by reading not any of
the books that had been published about
him although I had read one long before
but instead reading the letters that
Louis wrote to his family beginning when
he was about 10 years old when he first
when he went to boarding school first in
China and then at Hotchkis and then at
Yale and these these letters are really
an extraordinary chronicle of this young
man's life and he was a very interesting
young man and in many ways a very
impressive and attractive young man and
I think that helped me get through the
rest of his life in which he wasn't
always as attractive but was always
interesting and so I I I have a have a
number of friends who write biographies
David McCullough for example once told
me that he started out to write a
biography of Picasso and then discovered
that he loathed
so when he couldn't write about him I I
don't feel that way about writing I can
write about people I'd despised as
easily as I could write about people I
like but I I I came to the end of this
book feeling that Luce had many flaws
many things I disagreed with but also
many very attractive qualities including
among other things his very early
commitment to racial justice very rare
in the 20s when he began writing about
he and Britt hadn't both began writing
contemptuously about lynching and the
failure of outlawing it as a Republican
he was in fact a kind of moderate to
liberal Republican and his great
champions in the Republican Party were
Wendell Willkie and Dwight Eisenhower
both of whom he liked because they were
not part of the right wing of the
Republican Party and his son believes
that in 1964 he voted for Johnson
although I don't think there's any
absolute certainty about that so I think
Luce was a more complicated and more
interesting person than some of the
early characterization sofyan have been
certainly he could be a very difficult
person to work for and work with but as
a biographer I I found him
extraordinarily interesting from
beginning to end somebody else yes could
you stand please
so the so the question was who is it
that gets angry at the thought of Henry
are loose and before I turn it over I'll
just quick anecdote about my own story
so as you've been told I was appointed
to Henry are loose professor of social
thought ethics when I when it came to
Yale and I'm young enough to only know I
was supposed to not like loose I didn't
know what it was about him I was
supposed to not like so who is it that
knows enough and why well I think it's a
it's a legacy of it goes back many many
years and it's a legacy loose announced
that he was four things that most of his
critics were either suspicious of or
hated he was a Republican a Christian a
capitalist and a patriotic American
Republican capitalist Republic you know
patriotic American last refuge of a
scoundrel and Christian well is
missionaries sort of in bad odor you
know missionaries not so hot and so for
on four counts there was something wrong
I would argue that a lot of people who
got mad at Lou and my mother's
generation and so on got mad at Lou's
partly because he was right about a lot
of things in Barrett and they were
embarrassed about it there were my
mother
attitude quote my sainted mother yet
again was when she was just a kid I mean
mid teenager she joined the Communist
Party and then very quickly found out
that that about the the Moscow trials
and so on and as every intelligent
American communist did and she quit
almost immediately whereupon she was
named an enemy of the people looking at
age of sixteen or seventeen but but she
was wrong and people were wrong about
Stalin people were the about Mao it's
possible to to argue that Chiang
kai-shek was incompetent or at least his
people were
RuPt an incompetent so on but Mao didn't
prove to be the the Cultural Revolution
and the great bleep great deep forward
did not prove to be quite as wonderful
as in in the in the 1972 issue of the
new of in September of 1972 the review
the issue of the New Republic that
reviewed the Swanberg book right after
the review of the Swanberg book came a
review of the latest issue of Mao
Zedong's
poetry and it was the most embarrassing
leaf a Chua's article ever this was at
the height of the Cultural Revolution
when Red Guards were dragging professors
out of their offices and beating them
sometimes to death and and this
incomparably fatuous article in The New
Republic was talking about how wonderful
it was to have a poet in the magre
helmsman and so on and so there was a
lot of people who were very wrong about
a lot of things who resented the fact
that Luce was about a number of things
quite right but I think it's a legacy of
all that stuff whether whether people
whether younger people feel this sort of
animus I just don't know I mean I don't
know a lot of I I hope some of them
remember who Luce was but it's hard for
me to judge that Alan well I think a lot
of the dislike of Lewis were primarily
the dislike of public but it's like of
Luce was after World War two when he
became a much more fervent Republican
than he had been in the past and
especially during the Eisenhower years
the the the magazine time anyway
was really extraordinarily slanted
towards Eisenhower not just during
campaigns but during the entirety of his
of his presidency and that was partly
because Eisenhower was the first and
only president with whom Luce had a
really strong social connection their
personal connection somewhat with Lyndon
Johnson and John Kennedy but primarily
with Eisenhower and I think that that
was at least in my memory as a as a boy
in a house where both my parents read
time and life my mother you know would
spout with anger at times when she would
read a time magazine though she read it
every week and my father who was a
journalist and had a more detached view
you know read time with some equanimity
but also read Newsweek and lots of other
magazines and never had that kind of
anger but I think I think it was a
political anger more than anything else
a partisan anger it be a little bit
although not nearly as intense as
liberals looking at Fox News today but
not nearly so but he would but that they
were angry I mean it wasn't as if he was
supported he was supporting Eisenhower a
moderate as you pointed out but it
wasn't as if he was supporting Jenner
and Welker and McCarthy and Kaye part
and people like that I mean as these
things go Eisenhower was pretty much
middle-of-the-road except on China and
he embraced the most reactionary figures
in the China Lobby at various times but
on the whole I think you're right that
that he was a moderate Republican
through most of his life
well I don't know how many people here
have read the American century but I'm
sure some of you have I'm sure you have
and I think one thing you have to
remember is that this was a piece of
propaganda written in 1941 before
America entered the war and it was an
effort to shock the American people into
understanding the importance of America
getting into the war so a lot of what
was in that essay was a very specific
effort to change popular views at a
moment a very important transitional
moment in the movement towards the war
but of course in the essay there is also
a lot more than that and it does present
a vision of the world that I think Luce
really believed in that that the United
States represented a kind of Democratic
triumph in the world that would usefully
and morally be transmitted to other
nations all around the globe and that's
I think one of the things that people
find so odd reading the the American
Century today because that's not a view
that at least most people in this room
probably would would find comfortable I
agree with everything that Allen said
about
the context in which the American
Century editorial was printed by the way
loose regretted came to regret the
actual title I think he was a little
sheepish about because it had a
triumphal or Imperial note about it that
that he hadn't intended Henry Wallace
later responded by saying oh no that's
nonsense we need the century of the
common man and there was a certain
amount of Kant in what he had to say but
I think the context of trying to get
Americans involved in in a really
desperate world situation explains why
why he published a editorial I disagree
with the idea that I don't really read
that as a as a has a an aggressively
imperialist or fun sword a triumphal
kind of American statement I I think
that it's an extension of the missionary
universalism in which Christ said go ye
therefore and teach all nations loose
loose was perhaps before anything else
an educator and he believed in
he believed in in an evolution toward a
phrase that he very frequently used was
the kingdom of God his father also very
often mentioned the kingdom of God and
it was a progressive evolution toward
something and I think that he regarded
the American as it is true of course
that it did there was something quite
provincial it's it's I suppose you could
call it Imperial provincial ism or
provincial imperialism there was
something Imperia provincial about this
idea and there still is there wasn't you
know the the the twenty-first century
version of the same idea but I I don't
quite read it as
as a triumphalist or any such thing I I
read it as a more as his intentions as
being somewhat more benign and also
urgent in the context of what was
happening in Europe and was about to
happen in the Pacific
the question was if we could hear
something more about Lucis time at Yale
how was experience that Yale influenced
him and what he was connections with
Yale were after you graduated well I
think one thing you have to think about
when you think about Lucis time at Yale
is how different it was from what it is
today
it was at the very beginning of Yale's a
movement out of this very conservative
strict classical education and at the
very beginning of a sort of modern
liberal arts curriculum I and not yet
achieved when when Luce was there one of
the things that characterized loose in
the early 20th century was this sense
that yes it was fine to be at Yale and
take classes and and have an academic
life but the really important thing was
to work for Yale in some way and
everybody who was ambitious at Yale had
to make some kind of mark and Yale B
being the editor of the Yale Daily News
or being the head of the literary
magazine or being an athlete or most of
all being in one of the secret societies
especially skullenbones which was a
Lucis greatest ambition I am one of the
things he was most proud of all of his
life
so Yale was to him one of the highlights
of his life because he felt that he had
been a great success there even though
he had been enormous he disappointed
that Britt hadn't became the president
of the Yale Daily News and he had to
settle for managing editor anybody else
yes
the question was please speak on hit
loses position on Hitler and the Jews
I'm I'm trying to think of the of the
exact sequence of there was there was
the layered Goldsboro period in the 30s
layered Goldsboro was this rather
supercilious and slightly strange man
who was his foreign editor whom he
finally cashiered but in the during the
mid-30s Goldsboro was given to writing
it's almost flippant things about
Mussolini for example and and and about
Germany too I guess
and I'm I would let Alan do that because
I'm trying to I'm searching my mind to
try to pinpoint the answer but well Luce
would loosen actually loosen only very
glancingly Goldsboro never said anything
approving about Hitler but I wouldn't
say that Hitler was a great center of
Lucis world and nor did time devote
enormous efforts to discredit Hitler
until the war began broke out and I
think time dealt responsibly with a
Holocaust but I wouldn't say it was a
great leader in introducing Americans to
the Holocaust during the war I don't
think there's anything in Lucis
relationship with with the Third Reich
that would be morally abhorrent but
neither would I say that he was a great
champion of defending the Jews and well
there's a great deal of criticism as you
know of Franklin Roosevelt's behavior in
this regard and as far as media were
concerned
Edward r murrow late in the 30s was
getting rockets from the CBS
office in New York saying you know you
guys are being unfair you're not being
fair and balanced in your coverage of
the Third Reich you should be fairer to
Hitler and this was a guy forgotten the
name of the guy in the New York office
who sent this memo to Murrow but Murrow
was quite outraged rightly outraged by
it Murrow and his boys as they were
called were very very rough on rough
they were just telling the truth and but
I mean you have to point out that there
were an awful lot of people including
Franklin Roosevelt who were pretty sled
in the New York Times who were very slow
on this so I wouldn't blame Harry Luce
necessarily on that point anybody else
the question was hearing a bit the
request to hear a bit more about loose
as media mogul and I think what we're
looking for some practical suggestions
about how to become one loose loose
spent the 20s you know the it's it's a
well-known that Britain hadn't more or
less edited the magazine through the 20s
indeed until his death in 1929 lose
spent the twenties learning how to be a
businessman and it I think it's one of
the secrets of the longevity of the the
one of the one of the characteristics of
his magazines was the duration of their
success it's remarkable a lot of
magazines like McClure's magazine for
example which was a sensation early in
the century with a lot of you know
muckraking articles McClure's went up
and down pretty quickly The Saturday
Evening Post went on for years and years
but Luce had a string of extraordinary
successes and one of the reasons for
this was that he he I think had spent so
much time learning all through the 20s
until Hadden's death to be a businessman
and he learned he knew that business
very very well I think one of the things
that would seem strange to people
looking at media corporations today is
how important to loose it was to invest
heavily in the quality of his magazines
and that was one of the the consistent
pieces of his of his life as a creator
of magazines he and the people around
him believed that the best way to be
successful is to spend a lot of money
and create great quality and you'll make
more money that way than trying to do it
on the cheap I don't think there are
many people who think that way right now
but
I think it did work for loose
Ian could you stand up the question was
did loose foresee the fact that we were
moving towards a much more segmented
media market and I suppose we'd want to
say culture more generally it did he
foresee it if so what did he say about
it and what thoughts you might have
about his thoughts
well Luce were tired in 1964 and the the
real sort of breakdown of social unity
was only just beginning to occur so it I
don't think you would find in Lucis time
as head of Time Inc a full realization
of how fragmented American culture was
becoming by the time he died in 1967 he
was much more aware of this and and
didn't speak about it although not with
the same impact
he even experimented with LSD at one
point and was very interested in the new
left not particularly admiring but very
interested in it but it's very hard to
to know where he would have gone had he
lived longer I into the 60s except that
I don't think he would have been happy
about the the fragmentation of American
life anything that no I I think that's
right I think that he the one one thing
that strikes you about lose is the
the neatness with which he was born and
died he he was born in 1898 at exactly
the moment the spanish-american war
began and he died rather briskly in 1967
at exactly the moment when the United
States sank irrevocably into Vietnam and
in between from 1914 to 1945 was what
Neil Ferguson called the war of the
world which was one enormous so that the
world war so there was a trajectory in
Lucis life which was remarkably
symmetrical in a funny way and and
somehow what came after the
fragmentation and the diversity and so
on was outside the symmetry day in my
mind was outside the symmetry of his
life his his life had a curious kind of
completeness in that sense let me ask a
question that I've been wondering about
so loose is a moderate Republican and to
what extent can this be traced to his
own family upbringing I know nothing
about his parents his parents his
parents were basically social gospel
Christians who were who were very much
his father was very much involved in the
student volunteer movement which arose
in the 1890s and to evangelize the world
in one generation as they said they were
great admirers of Teddy Roosevelt's but
I mean Luce voted for Al Smith in 1928
he wasn't he wasn't he was never all of
his almost all of Lucis critics have
been to the left of him I know I know
very so they have seen him as more
conservative than in fact he was with
the exception as Alan says of China but
another point that I would make about
about the twenty all of Lucy's life was
spent in the presence not just of
constant incessant accelerating change
but in the presence of constant and
reading transformation he lived in in
there was a transformation absolutely
every respect that when he was a little
kid the empire's seriatim fell china
Czarist Russia Ottoman austro-hungarian
eventually the British all the empires
gone the fragmentation of China into a
warlord States World War one plus two
the the onset of Freud and Einstein and
machine guns and nuclear weapons and oh
one transformation you know automobiles
airplanes everything was in a state of
great transformation and this I think
affected his is one of the reasons that
when Mao was closing in on taking over
China Luce had been in the presence of
great transformation all of his life and
he didn't see why it Nash's necessarily
should be accepted as a federal compli
that this enormous country of China
would suddenly become become mouse
except for the fact of Hiroshima and the
bomb the presence of the bomb and some
people including Luce and MacArthur and
Richard Nixon at some point started
using the adjective tactical in front of
nuclear weapons so that they there was
some talk in in that area of tactical
nuclear weapons but it was the nuclear
weapons that that had had introduced
such a radically new element into the
calculations that I think Lucis position
on China was comprehensible in light of
the entire context of the transformation
that he had seen through the entire 20th
century